i remember the doctor saying to me at
the time like if you
carry on doing this that you literally
kill yourself
we've all had moments in the group where
we've suffered in some way
with our mental health and i think the
minute we realize it's
it's getting really bad we just sort of
like rally together and
support each other and help each other
out with that
i feel like i was totally completely
happy until i was about 13
and i think that's when it all started
um happening really
i think i found like what real sadness
was because my nan died and i'd never
experienced someone like that so close
to me dying
then obviously what i look like coming
to play and being at school is like
so difficult i think after i kind of
held that in
because i didn't speak to anyone about
it
it then got really bad when i was older
because i didn't talk about it
it's more recently that i've actually
got better i think do you feel like when
when you actually talk more about it you
sort of
it sort of resonates with you more like
how you really feel or how you felt in
the past
i didn't realize but when i started
writing music i was actually writing it
about myself without realizing
i think the best way as artists that you
can help people
is yeah just by talking about it or
writing about it you know
i'm that person where someone's like are
you okay and i could be having the worst
day i'll be like
i'm fine i think the more we talk about
it the better and i know for me as well
i'm still
really learning how how to do that
myself i'm still very much
on a journey of being able to articulate
myself in the right way of how i'm truly
[Music]
feeling
i feel like i've got two like moments in
my life where i felt
really yeah really low and
the first was when my granddad died
because i'd never experienced grief
before
and it was such a shocking system it
felt like my world just came in my
room like crashing down because he was
like one of my best mates
and yeah that sort of spiraled my eating
disorder
and it got to the point where i just
literally
hated myself i think looking back now i
realized it was definitely
on me just trying to gain control of
something i had no control over what
happened to me at school
about you know losing my granddad about
my mom and dad at home
so for me the only thing that i could
control was what i ate and you know what
i did to myself
i remember the doctor saying to me at
the time like if you
carry on doing this like you literally
kill yourself
we've all had moments in the group where
we've suffered in some way
with our mental health and i think the
minute we realize it's
it's getting really bad we just sort of
drew like rally together and
support each other and help each other
out with that what what do you think
your lowest point
has been i think in school was like
pretty bad
but my family had no idea that i was
having a tough time at school and now
and i didn't want to disappoint them
in telling them that i was being bullied
at school or felt
really bad about myself because i didn't
want them to feel like they were to
blame
i keep saying to people i'm i'm getting
better i'm getting better but
i'm still not better
being famous is like having a bit of a
toxic relationship with someone
yeah if i go online and you know see the
fans
you know talking about how much we've
we've helped them i'm like okay this is
worth it
then on the other side it's like i just
caught you can't unfamous yourself can
you
wake up and be like i'm gonna go to asda
and not be famous when i go
and not get recognized that you can't
there's no off button
i i've absolutely loved speaking to you
and you're so great
and so such a lovely human so refreshing
to
yeah to have female pop stars like even
the world
we should hang out more i think yeah
absolutely
thank you you're amazing everyone love
you
see ya